hi in this module i'm going to talk
about neural networks a way to construct
nonlinear predictors via problem
decomposition
so when we started we talked about
linear predictor and there were two
linear in two ways first is that the
feature vector was linear function of x
and the way that the feature vector
interacted with the prediction was also
linear this gave you rise to lines
next we talked about non-linear
predictors but
keeping the same
linear machinery but just playing around
with the feature vector and by adding
terms like x squared you could get
quadratic predictors and so on
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to define neural networks where we
can just leave
b of x alone the future vector alone
and play with the way that the feature
vector results in the prediction
and that will allow us to get all sorts
of fancy stuff
so let me begin with a motivating
example
so suppose you're trying to predict
whether two cars are going to collide or
not so the input are the positions of
the two cars
so x1 is the position of car 1 and x2 is
the position of car 2.
and what you like to output is whether
y equals one whether there's it's safe
or y equals one whether y equals minus
one or whether they're wide or not
and
what is unknown here um is that
we're going to say that cars are safe if
they're sufficiently far so the distance
between them is at least one then we're
going to be safe you can visualize this
a true
um predictor as follows so here is x1
and x2 and
um
what is going to happen was you're going
to draw these two lines here
and anything any point that is over here
and anything that is over here is going
to be labeled as uh
plus which is safe and anything that's
in between is going to be labeled as
minus or that will collide
okay so let's do some examples here so
suppose we have a point zero two which
is this point here
um
this is safe
so y equals one two zero is also
safe and 0 0
is uh
here which is not safe
and 2 2
is -1 which is also not safe
okay so
as an aside this configuration points is
what was historically known as a xor
problem and was shown that
pure linear classifiers could not be
used to solve this problem you couldn't
draw a line to separate the blue and the
orange points but nonetheless we're
going to show how neural networks can be
used to
solve this
okay so the key intuition is the
idea of problem decomposition so instead
of solving the problem all at once we're
going to decompose it into two
subproblems
but first we're going to test if car 1
is to the far right of car 2.
and in the picture here that corresponds
to
simply this
region over here which we're going to
call
h1 so h1 is whether x1 minus x2 is
greater than equal to 1.
and then we're going to find another sub
problem testing whether car 2 is to the
far right of car 1
which is called h2
that corresponds to this
region over here
and then we're going to predict safe if
at least one of them is true so we just
add the 2 here which is either one or
zero and
if at least one of them is one then
we're going to return plus one
and by convention we're going to assume
that the sine of zero is uh
minus
one
okay so
um here are some examples here so
suppose we have zero two again so this
point
h1 says nope that's not on my side h2
says yep that's on my side and at least
one is enough to make the prediction
plus one
if you take two zero that's this point
um each one says yep h2 says nope and
then f is one because all it takes is
one
zero zero is this point both of them say
no and it's minus one and same with two
two both of them say no
it's minus
okay so so far we've just defined the
true function f
um
uh of course we don't know f
so
what we're going to do is try to
move gradually to defining a hypothesis
class and the first next step is to
rewrite f using vector notation
so here are the two intermediate sub
problems
and the predictor is f of x equals the
sine
and what we're going to do is to write
this in terms of a dot product between a
weight vector and a
future vector so here's the feature
vector
1 x 1
x 2
and then we're going to define a white
vector which is minus 1 and if you look
at the dot product it's going to be so
it's minus 1
plus x 1
minus x 2
and if that quantity is greater than 0
then we're going to return 1
otherwise return 0.
and you can verify that this is exactly
just a rewrite of this expression
and similarly if you reverse the roles
of x1 and x2 then you can rewrite
h2
as
in vector notation as well
now what we're going to do is we're
going to just
combine h1 and h2 by stacking them
so we're going to find this matrix which
is just the two
wave vectors here stacked up so we have
two rows here
and we're going to
multiply this matrix by the feature
vector
so remember left multiplication by a
matrix is just taking the dot product
with each of the rows of that matrix
and now this produces
a two dimensional vector and we're going
to test whether each component is
greater than or equal to zero
so in the end
h of x is going to be a two dimensional
vector
okay and now given that we can rewrite
the predictor
as simply the sine of the dot product
between 1 1 and h of x which is simply
the sum of the two components
so now we've written
f of x which is the true function in
terms of
a bunch of
matrix or vector multiplies
now everything in red here
are just numbers
and so far we've specified what they are
but
in general we're not going to know them
and we're going to have to learn them
from data
but
before we do that we're going to
preemptively see one problem that's
going to come up
and this problem we saw before when we
tried to optimize the zero one loss
so let's look at the gradient of h1 of x
with respect to v1
um we can plot this as follows so here
is um
this
score z
which is the dot product
and
this is h1
and this is just a step function so the
step function or threshold function is
just
whether d is greater than zero it's one
over here and zero over
here okay so now if you try to degrade
and descend on this uh you're just going
to get stuck because the gradients are
going to be 0 basically everywhere
so the solution is to replace this
threshold function with a more general
activation function sigma
which has more friendly gradients
so classically and by classic i mean
like in the 80s and 90s people use the
logistic function
uh as activation function which looks
like this
and this is just a kind of a smooth out
version of the threshold function
and in particular its gradients are
zero uh nowhere so that's just great so
the gradient you can always move in
progress
there is a caveat here which is that
if you look out here this this function
is pretty flat which means that the
gradient is actually approaching zero
which means that if you're out here then
you can get stuck or at least make very
slow progress
so
in 2012 the value activation was
invented
which just takes a max of x as z and
zero so that looks like this
so
if
the inputs to the value is less than a
zero then i'm just going to keep it clip
it to zero
and then otherwise i'm going to just
leave it alone
so now this function actually has
nice gradients over here so the green
never vanishes it's always you know
positive and bound away from zero
although over here it is zero
so it turns out empirically the value
activation function works really well
it's simpler in a lot of ways so it's
kind of become the activation function
of choice here
so
um the solution here is to replace this
threshold step function with an
activation function choose your favorite
i would choose the value and now you
have uh something that has
non-vanishing gradients
so
let's now define two layer neural
networks using the machinery that we've
so far
okay so we're gonna define some
intermediate set problems
so we start with a feature vector
v of x now i'm going to represent
vectors and matrices using these dots
so this is a six dimensional
feature vector but in general it's d
dimensional
um i'm going to next multiply it by this
weight matrix
which is going to be a
three by six but in general a k by d
matrix
and now that generates a three
three-dimensional or k-dimensional
vector i'm going to send it through this
non-linearity
activation function like the value or
the logistic
and we're going to get
a vector which i'm going to call h of x
okay so now given this h of x
i can now do prediction by taking h of x
and simply dot producting it with
a wave vector w
and if i take the sign
and that gives me the prediction of that
neural network
so one thing that's kind of interesting
here is that if you look at this
equation
it really pretty much looks like the
equation for a linear classifier the
only difference is now we have h of x
instead of v of x
so one way to interpret what neural
networks are doing is that
instead of using the original feature
vector we've kind of learned a smarter
representation and at the end of the day
we're still doing a linear
classification on top of that feature
representation so you can often people
think about neural networks as doing
feature learning for precisely this
reason
and finally
now we can define the hypothesis class f
is equal to set of all predictors
and the predictor is given parameterized
by
a weight matrix v and of weight vector w
defined up here
and we can let the weight matrix be any
arbitrary k by d
matrix
and we let w be any d-dimensional
vector
sorry this d should actually be okay
there i will fix that
okay
so
we have to find a hypothesis class that
corresponds to two layer neural networks
for classification
now we can kind of push this farther
we can go and talk about deep neural
networks so remember going back to
single layer neural networks aka linear
predictors we see that we take the
feature vector we take the dot product
with respect to a weight vector and you
get the score which can be used to drive
prediction directly in the regression or
take the sign to get classification
predictions um for two layer neural
networks we take phi of x we take the
dot product between
layer one's uh weight matrix
take element y's uh
activation function
and then multiply dot product with a
weight vector you get the score
and now
the key thing is that this piece v
apply v and then apply sigma you can
just iterate over and over again so
here's a three-layer neural network
big phi of x
which is a feature vector you multiply
by some matrix v one take a
non-linearity
multiply by another matrix take a
non-linearity
and then finally you get some
vector that you take the dot product
with w and you get the score which can
be used to power your predictions
so one small note is that i've left out
all the bias terms
for notational simplicity in practice
you would have
you know biased terms
okay and you can imagine just iterating
this um
over and over again but you know what is
this doing it it's kind of looks like a
little bit of abstract nonsense you're
just multiplying by matrices and
ascending through non-linearity and you
hope something good happens
and you know that's not com there's not
uh completely false but there are some
intuitions which we can derive
so one intuition is thinking about
layers as representing multiple
levels of abstraction
so in computer vision let's say the
input
is
an image
so you can think about the first layer
as computing some sort of notion of
edges
and the second layer when you multiply
matrix and you take a non-linearity you
compute some notion of object parts
and then the third layer you
um
multiply by matrix and apply some
nonlinearity you get some notion of
objects
now this is kind of just a story and we
haven't talked at all about learning so
this is definitely not true for all
neural networks
it turns out that
when you actually learn a network to
data and you visualize what the weights
are you actually do get some
interpretable results which is kind of
interesting and you know somewhat
surprising
so now there's a question of uh depth
so the fact that you take a feature
vector and you apply
some sort of transformation again and
again again to get a score
so why why do we do this so one
intuition that we talked about already
is this is representing different levels
of abstraction to kind of low level
pixels to high level object parts and
objects
another way to think about this is this
is performing multiple steps of
computation
just like in a classic program if you
get more steps of computation it gives
you more expressive power you can do
more things
you can think about each of these
operations is simply doing some compute
now it's it's maybe a kind of a foreign
type of compute because you're
multiplying by a crazy unknown matrix
but
what way we can think about this is that
you set up this compute computation and
learning algorithm is going to figure
out what kind of computation makes sense
for making the best prediction
um another piece of intuition is that
empirically it just happens to work
really well
which is not not to be understated
um if you're
looking for a more
theoretical reason
um
there are
the jury's kind of still out on this you
can have uh intuitions how um
you know deeper logical circuits can
capture more than shallower ones but
then there's like the kind of
relationship between circuits and neural
networks which is
requires a little bit of massaging so
this is still kind of a pretty active
area of research
so to summarize we start out with the
very toy problem the xor problem testing
whether two cars are going to collide or
not and we used it to motivate problem
decomposition and eventually defining uh
neural networks
we saw that
intuitively neural networks allow you to
define nonlinear predictors but in this
particular way
and the way is to decompose the original
problem into intermediate sub problems
testing of the cars to the far right or
the far left
and then combining them
over time
and you can kind of take this idea
further and iterate on this
decomposition multiple times giving rise
to multiple levels of abstraction
multiple steps of computation
a hypothesis class is now
larger it contains all predictors where
the weights of all the layers can vary
um freely
in the next up we're going to show you
how to actually learn the weights of a
neural network
that is the end